you're done
samson get away from me you wack no
remorse
not a bit none whatsoever
think you'll leave here alive ass white
claire this your new
driver i'd get out while i could if i
were you
claire can't seem to keep her partners
alive for long [ __ ] truth is
dean was a shitty husband as he was a
driver
head swelled lots larger than he could
manage and he paid for it
face the facts i didn't kill him
his ego did you're a waste of organic
matter samson
your corpo trash got a dozen bullets
with your name [ __ ] off
clear enough come on not to worry [ __ ]
do something for me
hey hang on give me your clothes
stay available
[Music]
excellent
[Music]
everyone ready three two
[Music]
one
hold on get on his butt
[Music]
me
[Music]
whew
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
oh
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
get on a spot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
let's take the wind out of his sails
[Music]
hmm
i don't know
how's life samson claire please
don't i i didn't do anything you
pathetic word is that so
hey now please don't let her do this
claire i beg you jesus what what the
[ __ ] you want i
i didn't kill dean zip your trap he got
himself killed for [ __ ] sakes please
let me go
walk your way out of this
time to die [ __ ]
wait no your husband wasn't the saint
you think
let's get out of here vee
oh
all over huh guess so
you're right claire what why
you look pretty down i'm not
be honest i don't think i feel anything
it's okay it'll get better
what will well everything i guess
we'll move on the only place i want to
go right now is my liquor cap
any desire to do it again team up
for a race i mean novi in fact
not gonna race ever again ever
ever that was something we had something
deen and i
shared i just needed you to get sampson
so
beast is yours wait what you're giving
me a rig
it's not mine belong to me andy
but since we are no more
take care v and watch those turns or
you'll end up wrapped around a lamppost
you